the Jo Rogan Experience my life got real
tough once I got to like once I left
home so my parents divorced at 15 like I
testified I never wanted to see my mom
again and then I I left with my Dad yeah
so you know the other the other branch
of that story is you got the abuse from
at least my earliest memory of was like
four and a half 5 years old and then
till 15 years old then we leave I go to
PA with my dad because my mom basically
hated my guts I was a it was like it was
such divided family it was the girls and
my mom that we lived like the farm life
like I grew up a farm boy and uh against
like my dad and the fighter right like
like I was a puppet and uh you know I
just mimicked everything that he said
but you know um I chose my dad because I
didn't want to lose wrestling or or
Jiu-Jitsu or or boxing and everything
but then when I got up meing but then
when I got up to PA he had already had a
girl he was laid up in that it was like
that's all that mattered to him and then
she worked he doesn't work you know what
I mean so he found somebody to pre on to
manipulate to do his thing and then it
was like I don't need my kid no more
after I went to court and like you know
I didn't understand the consequences of
testifying testifying in court against
your mom and being dragged to court out
of school and that
humiliation um and uh you know I didn't
talk to my my mom and my sisters for
years and we we don't talk currently we
haven't talked since before I got in UFC
and we haven't talked since before I
broke my arm wow because I knocked my
sister's boyfriend out for being a
methhead oh Jesus yeah yeah so yeah it
is what it is but uh but yeah man I mean
once I moved up to PA it got that was
the worst like that short span
from 15 to like 18 was like man like I
was ready to I was out so where were you
staying during that time so I stayed in
Media PA I lived in uh I lived in it's
it's Pennsylvania but it's like 25
minutes outside of uh Philadelphia so
it's like the suburbs city um honestly
it's like a bougie it's not bougie but
it's like a Towny nice town and uh you
know everything was new to me I came
from a school of 330 kids I got into
high school I was in a school of like
1600 kids across four grades but they
were all like preppy [__] like kids
down in South Jersey where I grew up
they were they were all fighting each
other like beating each other up jumping
each other after school up here
everybody would talk [__] nobody would
fight so it was like a weird it was a
weird thing for me to adjust I didn't
have friends I didn't have phone like
until I started getting a job and yeah
man it was weird it was really weird I
uh I lived in a two-bedroom apartment um
and my dad his girl at the time uh which
he's married to now um and her two
daughters we all lived in a two-bedroom
apartment you know what I mean so it was
like it was just like a bunch it was it
was a terrible living situation and then
at the beatings man I swear to God he
used to beat me up just to prove that he
could
beat me you know and show his girl that
he was tough and you know like nobody
could [__] with him type of deal and it
was just like man so it got real dark
man and started like stomping me
breaking my like broke my teeth um I got
two two crowns you know because of him
because it breaking my teeth and I would
I would curl up like he would punch me
like a grown man but I would curl up he
would throw uppercuts like that's how
intent this guy was on getting me and
um the last fight we had it was over a
[__] game called Uncharted three and
it was we were playing Co-op but because
I would get more kills than him this is
the kind of [__] he would rage at he so
and mind you throughout all these years
right he's on SSD the reason being he
had a car accident he was an oil truck
driver uh I I forget the story of who
blew the light but when he was gone
through the light he got T-boned or he
T-boned somebody bleow out his back had
to get surgery apparently it failed
whenever he wanted to jump up and whoop
your ass though dude wasn't crippled no
more so it's crazy you know and he would
go box 15 rounds but throughout 2004 all
the way until I was 15 years old and and
then some this man was on narcotics all
the time he was on Viking and perco oxy
and uh he he definitely was addicted
there was never a time that I didn't see
it the dude used to have like 60 [__]
bottles of it and um he would he would
take medicine and he would drink two
Yingling and I think when I look back
I'm like man like that [__] don't make a
[__] angry and uh
yeah I mean it just got worse as I got
older but I remember the last fight that
we had it was you know I used to I I
remember I used to look at him and be
crying and say you know like how come
you don't love me like what I got this
empty hole in my chest because I didn't
understand emotion so I I'd like try to
plead with him like yo like something's
wrong with me I got something I got a
hole I got like got a hole in my heart
like or my chest I don't know how to I I
don't even know how to explain it and uh
you know the things he would say in
rebuttal would be like K [__] kill
yourself your feelings don't matter shut
the [__] up when I say jump you say how
high like it was there was no remorse
for anything he did and I think that's
why I despise him um you know the dude
hurt
me uh he hurt me for a lot of years that
I had to repair um and even then I still
carry over some bad bad attitude
problems and uh you know the dude
[__] it got to the point where it was
like either I'm gonna kill myself or
I'mma kill him and finally he beat me
half to death the one day I mean beat me
half to death and uh I packed a bag of
clothes and he came out he pulled a
[__] knife on me said he was going to
kill me with it I shoved them ran out
the [__] door never went back Jesus
Christ never went back at but how old
were you then 16 I was just turning I
was I I was either 16 and the week after
17 I don't remember um but I was it I
was within two weeks of turning 17 when
I left um or I just turned 17 and then
left so uh it was in the month of
September God damn and yeah so I left
slept in the park for a couple nights
and uh then I wind up standing up for a
kid uh a black kid that was getting
called Rachel slurs and that was my
first friend I had made and uh yeah I
mean he wind up having uh he definitely
was on the Spectrum like he he wasn't
the smartest kid um unfortunately like
he he had some things that uh people
would pick on him for um like being
overweight and and he would say some
weird stuff and whatnot but uh yeah he
was the first f friend that I developed
and um his brother was in juvie for
arson trying to light somebody's house
on fire and he was adopted by a white
man so but the house that they lived in
bro it was like the most disgusting
living environment you could [__]
think of catpiss infested hoarder of
comics that were all destroyed from
catpiss
um like every part of the house would
have been sticky like your shoes would
stick to the [__] floor um and there
were [__] everywhere the smell was like
like a pneumonia um maggots in the sink
because he refused for about four years
to fix the garbage disposal that's how
long it sat there Broken Live Wire on
the overhead of the oven so I lived in
there um and I wind up with I used to
run papers to the courthouse and make
like 75 bucks a week so every time I
would make a little bit of money and his
dad would give me some money sometimes
to like try and help uh like straighten
up the house and I would buy bleach and
[__] bleach [__] and try to clean and
bro it was disgusting like you could
wash your clothes six [__] times and
it would still smell like cat piss in
pneumonia and it was a very embarrassing
very
humbling way to live and I lived off in
like instant food like microwave food
for the next two years all my wrestling
high school years and the next two years
that I was there everything was either
donated food from my wrestling coach um
will Harman who [__] man that that
was my Saving Grace when I went to that
school you know I don't want to miss
that part like that's important to me
that man is the whole reason I'm in the
UFC now wow so um godamn dude those were
the living conditions man like I mean I
mean [__] and he my wrestling coach
would come to the house you know then I
had truy officers coming after me
because I miss so much school um it was
either dius or some child services at a
certain point that was like who's taking
care of you who's your caregiver and you
know I had a nasty response for him and
nothing kind of came of it but it was
like do I look like I'm [__]
unhealthy I remember slamming the door
in the woman's face cuz I thought they
were going to try and take me from the
house but uh but yeah man it was shitty
times and uh you know life beat you up
in ways that you're not prepared for and
doesn't change no matter how much money
you make no matter you're here you're
here there's always going to be a
problem it's just how you roll with it
so well for sure but having been through
the problems that you've been through I
guarantee you you know how to navigate
problems better than most
people I voice it a lot you know people
always think I'm
bitching but I just I'm bro and I am
sometimes I [__] you know because
that's my way of coping I'll put it out
there so it's not stuck inside and
that's something that's worth for me you
know I say a lot of things that I feel
and uh as long as I get it out I'm happy
you know what I mean or any at least I'm
settled I don't have that like anger
like waiting to explode you know that's
the you ever think of where you would be
if it wasn't for martial arts in that
same situation
I would killed myself 100% I I struggled
even when I had it you know and and
that's
the it's one of the only things that
gets people out yeah I just I just
didn't see a life for me man I was so
stupid and when I say stupid like the
whole time that my dad's a stay at- home
Dad and and I want to give credit to my
mother too you know my mother I never
really felt like loved me that much and
uh you know it is what it is but uh my
mom worked her ass off off and that's
why I get my work ethic that woman held
two jobs she did what she could to
provide she wasn't you know she wasn't a
bum she would she tried and she did the
best she could with a dude like that you
know what I mean she was she never had
another man still hasn't had another man
to this day she was married to him for
20 years they had five blood kids and uh
yeah I mean I owe my mom respect for
that because she's a hardworking woman
and uh didn't matter she she used to
work at shopright Home Depot those were
her two jobs and CNA and you know she
she did what she could you know so I
respect her for that and um yeah I mean
[__] man that dude was not teaching us H
school was my point for years you were
afraid to ask him to [__] give you a
spelling
be because he was sitting at the [__]
computer playing games so if you did it
what the [__] do you want what the [__]
are you bother me like it was always a
huge like explosion so you're a kid and
you know from getting beat by this
person it's like I don't want to make
him mad he might [__] slap me he
might hit me he might do something so
all of us were scared we didn't [__]
learn anything I tested again in public
school [__] they held me back I
was dumb as
[__] like it is what it is so uh yeah I
mean so my point is making light of
something you know dark you know but
then coming back to the dark side man if
if I didn't have MMA I don't I don't
think I would be successful um I don't
think I would have been strong enough I
don't think I would have had confidence
and uh I think life would have broke me
man I think I would have I would have
taken I would have taken you know the
easy way
out